what are y'all taking me in for what did
I do operating vehicle while under the
influence of alcohol or drugs or other
controls no a belligerently intoxicated
woman is arrested in Ohio after crashing
a vehicle while transporting a patient
with special needs Kelly I'm gonna have
you step out with me okay we got we
gotta go I know I got to get you out of
here though okay
I know you're not gonna do that yeah
Kelly we're not laying back down all
this before she blatantly and repeatedly
flirts with First Responders on the
scene let me tell you something what I
would do to you with your blue
the crash happened on May 11th in Blue
Ash Ohio about 20 minutes Northeast of
Cincinnati 48 year old Kelly Barton an
employee at the Ohio Valley Residential
Services Group Home was transporting a
special needs patient in a vehicle when
she crashed you know how you had too
much to drink you just want to lay down
yeah that part okay
um
body camera video shows officers
speaking with Barton's co-worker who was
called to the scene after the crash she
explains what happened this is what
happened
client is in the car
and uh he said she hit a Lamppost in the
middle of the street
that's what he said Barton's co-worker
says the patient in the vehicle says she
hit a lamp post before pulling into a
gas station I've been at work since
seven o'clock this morning so I don't
know if she hit something in the middle
or what but Robert just keeps saying she
hit a Lamppost
okay and she said she had to avoid a
hall I don't know what this is she
shredded the back of that she's in the
back of my car well she popped both
tires so I'm afraid she hit something in
Blue Ash so
uh I guess it's going to be by the
roundabout that's what I think too well
you're saying she came Glendale Milford
yeah oh
[Music]
yeah okay so here's here's what she told
me
the driver
is in her car okay so I came to an empty
vehicle all right
the owner of this
facility or whatever it is
they
they transport specials
[Music]
foreign
I'm just wondering a sense of
the OVI charts
Lincoln
plan
Barton's co-worker then explained she's
new to the job and lives in a shelter
nearby we got to figure out what we're
gonna do with her do you know where she
goes yeah she's down at the um she's at
the shelter on Reading Road
your drivers is someone that stays in a
shelter
huh your driver is somebody who stays at
a shelter my co-worker she's a co-worker
she's okay but I'm the driver that's my
fault
yeah
this one yeah she stays in the shelter
job yeah we're trying to figure out a
way if we got to get her home we got to
figure out
yeah she's at the shelter a responding
officer can be heard on the phone
describing the situation to his Superior
so your situation it's a unique one
we're always 31 okay
our car belongs to a special needs
driver service they drive especially
people around two different places the
driver is heavily intoxicated she or see
we're going to go see what she hit in
Blue Ash but the
gentleman the them was being driven
said she had a pole uh the car is on
only one wheel
when I got here the car was turned off
and this driver is sitting in the
passenger seat of a co-workers car that
came in to pick up the special needs for
us
so
can we even go the old guy around
nobody saw her driving lady picked her
up said my boss told me to come down
here and and come get her she and when
she came to find her so the reason they
found her is the lady that was driving
that's drunk called her boss saying hey
I need a tow truck because the car I hit
a pothole and a blew a tire so this lady
came to come pick them up and she's like
oh she's drunk officers then approached
Barton's co-worker's vehicle the patient
she was transporting Robert sits in the
front seat as Barton is passed out in
the back
oh how are you doing Robert
okay
oh hello there
yeah what's her name Kelly Kelly
yes how are you doing
good
Kelly would you be able to do you have a
driver's license with you
I want to do what the number yeah if you
know what that'd be great Barton admits
to officers she had too much to drink
but does not admit to driving Kelly did
you have anything to drink tonight yeah
how much
okay
were you driving no
how'd you get here
because I didn't never leave
okay so you drove out here what happened
officers then brainstorm how to confirm
Barton was behind the wheel so I got her
to say pretty much that she hits a drank
over my limits and she gave me her info
and that she'd been drinking and that's
it
she said no she said no
correct cameras
officers do confirm Barton was driving
by looking at gas station security video
and she gets charged with uh I think
it's neglect because if he's got this if
he's disabled
and here she comes and I don't see how
the time is it
20 30. 18 we'll say 20.
15.
and then it's uh 511 perfect thank you
sir we'll have an investigator come down
and get that from you what time's a good
time
two yeah all right thank you sir
appreciate it
yeah it looks faster no problem
he's been here oh she came into 2033
so long
it's been how long two hours what's the
time frame
really
you're right she's been that long yeah
that's the correct time on there right
maybe it's like 10 to 2 minutes
yeah I think it's three hours I think
it's three we gotta get going let's go
it's then that officers work to get
Barton out of her co-worker's back seat
Kelly yes sir I'll meet you step out of
the car for me okay
we got to do some stuff and then we're
gonna figure out what we're gonna do
okay y'all want to do all this to me
well come on let's talk I didn't say
you're gorgeous you know what you look
like the movie
which movie
what y'all want to do well what I'm
gonna do is ask you a few questions okay
come on come on over here for me okay
you can hold my hand if you need to
come on uh you want your shoes too
got your shoes in there what is they
doing
Kelly I mean just step out with me okay
yeah I'll talk to you right now yeah
you're gonna have to step out with me
okay it'll be easier this way and I'll
get you your shoes Okay so come on
but I need you to step outside
yeah how about this I'll let you lean up
on my car
I know
but Kelly let me get you out here and
I'll have you step outside and stand by
my car
yeah let's go ahead just get this normal
Squad
hey Kelly yes sir can I have you step
out here with me real quick
I'll help you out I know here we go give
me your hand and I'm gonna help you out
I know you're trying but I need you to
work with me okay so this is nice lady
can give you a ride home okay
so go ahead and step out for me all
right
officers work for several minutes to
convince Barton to step out of the
vehicle Kelly I know you're tired here
hold my hand and I'm Gonna Get You Out
okay so I need you to come out with me
all right
because we're gonna work together okay
listen to my partner please
yeah come on Kelly please I'm gonna get
you I'm Gonna Get You these shoes all
right
just sit back up just sit back up for me
and come on out we have an ambulance
coming to check you out just make sure
you're okay
you can tell them you don't want them
but we need it's part of our policy okay
but Kelly I need you to hop out of this
car for me okay yes sir very well come
on
I got your hand I'll help you out ready
here we go there we go
all right now get your feet out
Kelly go ahead and get your feet out for
me okay let's get this this foot right
here first
and I'll let you lean up on my car okay
because I have to all right so come on
out with me okay I appreciate you just
come on out I'm a pretty nice guy what
am I is this coming but you can't get
the ambulance to check out here
so come on out for me Kelly
I know I get you you see those shoes
let's get your foot out so I can get you
in these shoes too okay
I just got the umbrella opportune too
I'll help you I'll help you out okay I'm
gonna grab this right here
we got your shoes there we go we got
your shoes here
baby there we go
you ain't going anywhere you just gotta
come out with me okay
we gotta check you out come on Kelly I
have it you got Lotus
how are you doing sir can you get his
information too sir his name Robert yes
sir that's hers Kelly I'm gonna have you
step out with me okay we got we gotta go
I know I gotta get you out of here
though okay
I know you're not gonna do that yeah
Kelly we're not leaning back down I just
need to step out with me okay
that's my food go take her food
we'll get some food too okay
come on come on Kelly Y'all work with me
sweetheart you gotta love me sweetie pie
yeah
let me go no no no no I'm done Kelly I
need you to get out of the corner I know
you have it but I need you just gotta
take him home she has to go home and I'm
going home soon
you gotta get out of the car Kelly I'm
not letting you lay back down so please
please
he needs to go back to sleep okay I'm
gonna get you to sleep too don't go
there with me take a nap don't go there
with me take a snooze I get you we're
still alive
come on finally Barton gets out of the
car just step out with me okay
yeah I'm not putting you in the car or
anything I just need to step out of this
one okay with my phone
you gotta come on out come on out you
got to come on out Kelly okay I've been
super nice I've been super reasonable
with you but I need you come out okay
I need to get out of this car so you're
gonna take the gentleman home okay okay
yeah he just gotta go home okay careful
yeah leave me alone
I'm gonna have you just step over here
with me when officers tell Barton she
will be checked out by EMS responders
she begins flirting calling the workers
handsome you really listen to the
officer
okay so let me go I need you to come
over here
I just need to step over here okay you
got to walk away yes sir thank you okay
well these ambulance people are going to
come talk real fast
do you make sure you're okay
let me ask you this
let me ask you this man
can I run a series of tests can I check
your eyes and have you do a couple yeah
and I'm a pass or anything that she's
trying to do as they work to take her
blood sugar Barton continues flirting
with First Responders look at your
handsome you want the lights guard to
check you man
love do what they gotta do come on boys
I want the little young boys asking me
how I'm feeling let the little young boy
[Applause]
she doesn't want you man
who all want me toon doesn't want who
won't want me I want you you're good
you're cool with me okay you ain't gotta
want me let me tell you something what I
would do to you with your blue so let me
check your blood sugar
what is y'all doing to me out here
tonight okay huh ready here we go
ready right here
that's it
what's your date of birth May 28 1974.
Here Comes Gemini look at you you so
damn handsome thank you
Landers
Landers yep that's that's the last thing
yo I'm ready for me now
and I don't think so either can I put a
Band-Aid on you
ah you guys why I'm bleeding yeah I'm
gonna put a Band-Aid on it
look at you my answer yeah
what's up
this theme continues as officers ask
Barton to participate in field sobriety
tests look at him okay I will do him in
a way that he won't admit hey look he
can look tough while he won't right
don't let me get it you look the truth
and you got
eyelashes like my son it's pretty nice
aren't they
they are Barton then begins to take a
series of tests all right so Kelly
here's what I'm gonna ask you do you
have any neck injuries head injuries
back injuries
do you wear glasses or contacts have you
been to the hospital recently for
anything
outstanding what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna take your eyes all right what I
need you to do is Stand Together
arms to your side okay yeah
keep your arms to your side what's that
all right it feels like this all right
like this perfect and what I want you to
do is you're going to follow the tip of
this pen right here okay with your eyes
and your eyes only okay so nothing else
ready
try to keep your head still
next thing we're gonna do is going to
the walk and turn okay so you're gonna
stand right there where you are exactly
like this I know you're seeing their
feet together arms to your side okay
well I'll explain this
what you're gonna do is on that line
you're going to take nine Heel To Toe
steps okay I'm going to show you so
you're going to go Heel To Toe
you're gonna count out loud one two
three until you get to nine on the ninth
step you're going to keep one foot
position down small series of steps and
then nine heel toes-ups back do you
understand okay let's go all right go
ahead and begin
right
yep
the next thing we'll do is a one leg
stand okay so you're gonna have your
feet together arms to your side all
right I'm gonna let you pick a foot left
or right what you're gonna do is you're
going to take it you're gonna Point your
toe forward and You're Gonna Keep it
about
six inches off the ground okay you're
gonna look at your toe you're gonna
count out loud one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand so on so
forth until I tell you to stop
so if I don't do it then what you don't
have to if you don't want to but it's
one of the tests I'm going to try to get
you to do okay okay come on what you say
all right feet together onto your side
you can pick either foot okay you're
gonna pick it up six inches off the
ground Point your toe forward you're
gonna count out loud one one thousand
two one thousand three one thousand
until I tell you to stop okay
and if I don't then what I'm gonna
marking that you did not take the test
but I'm about to do all right go ahead
and begin so how far though
you keep going until I tell you to stop
okay and you just lift your foot up
six inches off the ground
just like this
one one thousand two one thousand three
one thousand okay this is the last one
you ready I'm ready
you know I can't do it okay you know I
can't do it okay
wait a minute okay for your safety we're
just gonna stop right there okay she
then confirms with officers she does not
have a home address and stays at a
shelter she also says she couldn't pass
the tests even if she was sober I'm
gonna give you an opportunity to take a
breath test okay if you want to submit
to a breath test okay what we gotta do
we gotta take it back to the PD just so
we can get over that paperwork okay
what's BC or please for me and then you
need to tell me where your home address
is so we can get you a ride home I don't
have a home address do you say the
shelter
I don't have a home address where do you
stay
a little shelter in a shelter we'll
figure something out okay hold on let me
y'all
well we're done even if I was sober I
couldn't do this test okay after that
officials put Barton into handcuffs
that's no problem what I gotta do though
until we get the PD I'll take you right
back out I gotta put you in handcuffs
okay so I'm gonna have you put your
hands behind your back all right no
Stanley I need you to relax with me okay
right here oh listen why are you and
Company
um I got two fingers in this one just in
case
look we put three on there we put three
on there to be comfy yeah don't do that
Kelly we got 300 it's so pleasant we've
been Pleasant to you
okay
Kelly
okay she's already too resistant
no you are no we don't need any more
cuffs I didn't know there's too much
just listen to him and everything will
go fine okay
officers then struggle to get Barton
into the back seat of a squad car what
are y'all taking me in for what did I do
operating vehicle while under the
influence of alcohol or drugs
you have anything on you yep any cash in
your pocket do anything at all in your
pockets
I don't know
there's something back here so what is I
don't know help me out oh okay I got it
I got it
it's the key to the Toyota nice
unlock my hands
that was the key
yes sir very good we're gonna go to this
side of the car here all right I'm gonna
have a seat in my car
five minutes tops of the police
department will be back out of the car
but as long as you keep being nice we're
gonna take those handcuffs right back
off but my policy says that I have to
have your handcuffed that's my boss
right there you don't want me getting in
trouble dude I don't get in trouble
what you got me for now
no
oh
Kelly Kelly you got to get the seat
Kelly come on just work with me
you gotta hear me out there we'll get
these companies
I know but you got to work with us here
okay and we'll get these custom right
back off but you got to listen to us all
right we've been super nice let's just
work with us y'all ain't nice okay just
let's go ahead and take a seat here we
go
just be careful okay watch your head
Kelly come on come on Kelly
come on now
apparently we're gonna help you out but
you got to work
there's plenty of room in the car I'll
put on whatever radio station you want
me to I don't want to hear no milk
we're good I'm gonna step forward step
forward Kelly you got to get in the car
gotta sit down in the car hold on man
hold on
Kelly you have to get my car
all right there we go because you're
under arrest what for what come on
operating a vehicle while I'm talking
she's going straight now
yeah all right I'm going straight down
if you don't sit in the car
we need you to sit in this car
there you go I'm going straight down
take a seat in the car wait a minute I'm
going straight down to the PD if you
just sit in the car okay so I'm about to
sit down sit down scoot your rear end up
okay get your legs in now perfect there
you go you're almost there I know it's a
little bit higher up
you're good
I know work with me Kelly okay
you can work with me I'm gonna work with
you but you got to get up in this car
please get your legs thank you thank you
thank you you're good there you go thank
you Kelly
very good and we'll get the seat belt on
okay yes sir
take this off with her
okay y'all emotional please as soon as
we get back I'm gonna take them off
please y'all just loosen them you ain't
got to take them off
as officers explain Barton's charges she
yells out in disagreement
Kayla I gotta read a piece of paper to
you okay oh why because I have to all
right well found a piece of paper well
it's explaining why you are where you
are dude you're so handsome he's gonna
help me read this too okay yeah
sometimes he doesn't know how to read
yeah
I ain't doing nothing that'll go really
well with that listen y'all I have not
done nothing here we go and then look I
got a bad day like almost like needles
right I don't like nobody sticking me
with needles but just what you have done
in me like okay Kelly you are now under
the arrest for operating vehicle Under
the Influence alcohol drug or can the
combination of them operating vehicle
under the influencer motion controlled
substance
shine
by law you have your hydraulic
privileges to be suspended immediately
and you have the right to pay to have
your privileges reinstated if you have a
CDL and refuse to submit the chemical
tests
and you'll be disqualified from
operating a commercial motor vehicle
into a period
it'll be required to surrender
if you have a product review of your
operating vehicle
substance or listen to controlled
substance
understate foreign
[Music]
oh no
you guys are used to use our equivalent
offense in the previous 20 years
and if you submit the chemical test
require law I'm authorized using
whatever reason
Barton was later charged with operating
a vehicle impaired and patient
endangerment she was also fired from her
transportation job reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie